i know what you're really here for
[Music]
that's cute though yes netflix's latest
comedy series with a pretty big cast has
just launched
get it launched oh god just kill me and
think story is back for a deep dive into
the ending so strap yourselves in
because here we
go the last episode begins with the
joint chiefs of staff the heads of the
army navy marines air force space force
and yes
even the coast guard hey guys what are
you doing
[Music]
coast guard oh come on man they need to
retaliate against the chinese after the
american flag was so disrespectfully run
over you'd think the president
would be involved in a meeting which
could escalate tensions between two
superpowers
but the show purposely refrains from
showing the president
and even the first lady that's because
the show hints that the president in
this world
is donald trump dropping some
not-so-subtle clues throughout the
season
like how he doesn't believe in climate
change do we have any missions ready to
launch
the climate orbiter not that why not
it's ready to go
you know why tweets when he gets angry
potus is pissed
i'm going to his birthday party right
now expect a nuke storm on twitter or
how he texts mark that sex is only for
winners
we're gonna keep winning and winning and
winning heck even the space force itself
was established by the president in 2019
in an effort to find ways to design a
proportionate response mark nerd the
head of space force has tasked his media
manager
tony scara paduchi with putting together
a focus group and it's no coincidence
that tony's character is a satire of
tony scaramucci
trump's former communications director
who lasted only 10 days on the job the
show plays a lot with character names
some more subtle than others for example
in episode 3 we learn this young
congresswoman from new york annabel
yisidro campos or
ayc for short is a take on the real life
congresswoman from new york
aoc alexandria ocasio-cortez even mark's
air force antagonist kik
gravestone has a name worthy of his
misogynist character
grab ass ton hmm no
panty lines on the angry young
congresswoman so this focus group comes
up with some amazing ideas like tping
the chinese rocket or writing china
sucks on the side of their base
meanwhile mark's daughter aaron has
defaced kelly's car
she doesn't like how this new woman has
come into her father's life and could
potentially take away the only person
she has left
with her mother in jail and her father's
time consumed by work
aaron feels abandoned 40 seconds
what i got 40 seconds
with my father so she does what many
teens do when feeling neglected by their
parents
she lashes out she gets fired from her
job for being drunk and later joins a
group of random strangers to head out to
a party
but we'll get to that in a bit we get an
image of the luxurious chinese base the
chinese are the main external threat of
space force throughout the season
and always seem to be one step ahead of
mark and the americans
in episode 1 they even cut the solar
panels off the new american satellite
which some may think is an
even greater act of aggression than
running over the flag
dr adrian mallory the head scientist at
space force pleads with mark to
de-escalate
they've just named the site where the
americans landed the plains of mallory
and he'd hate it to be the site of the
moon's first atrocity but behind
mallory's back mark informs captain ally
that their ship has secretly stored a
cache of guns
and when mallory hears about this he
quits he was told they didn't have room
for toothbrushes let alone
a half dozen guns mallory's abrupt
departure means dr
chan k fang takes over command he calls
captain ali to cheer up you can tell the
writers have been trying to establish a
romantic relationship between these two
pairing them up in several storylines
throughout the season like chan teaching
ali about botany or him
driving her to denver to get an eye exam
earlier in the season chan even talks
about how he's part of a facebook group
for asian men
and black women interested in dating
each other he says that even though it's
the least likely couple combination
you'd find they have the highest success
of staying together
now that she's on the moon and he's on
earth it will be interesting to see how
this relationship
blooms next season at home the thought
of sending his soldiers to battle weighs
heavily on mark
what if i don't know what the right
thing to do is
but you do that's because mark even
though he's a general of an armed force
a force with the power to kill
always thinks of the people that are
under him this is beautifully indicated
in episode three when mark explains why
an orange costs ten thousand dollars to
fly to the moon one thing you learn in
the military
is that money doesn't matter people
matter
someone who is putting their life on the
line in the pursuit of knowledge and the
betterment of mankind
should be allowed this simple luxury of
an orange marx care for others not only
applies to his work but to his family
he cares deeply about his wife and
daughter when he has a conjugal visit
with his wife who suggests they have an
open relationship
he's against it the only one for him is
his wife and he'll wait however long it
takes to be with her
because i would wait for you forever
because that is what i signed on for
when we got married
and even though he's not always there
for his daughter you know that he cares
about her after going 48 hours with no
rest at work
mark comes home and helps his daughter
with her math homework he's exhausted
but he's there for her
he may not always be but he makes the
effort mark's conversation with kelly
has inspired him to do the right thing
he's going to disobey the direct order
from the secretary of defense and not
retaliate against the chinese but to
defy this order he'll need doc's help
who is more than willing to undertake
this treasonous act
meanwhile aaron gets in the back of a
stranger's truck to head off to a party
but notice here there's a fun easter egg
in the background this missing person
poster
emmett bunton is the guy all the way
from episode one who mark arrested
stored in his trunk and put in jail i
guess they haven't let him out yet
duncan here informs mark that the
secretary of defense is on the line
duncan has been a potential romantic
relationship for mark's daughter but
nothing much seems to happen there this
season
largely due in part to aaron dating yuri
the russian who is obviously dating her
to get closer to mark and steal state
secrets
i must thank you the show also portrays
characters from the south as glaring
stereotypes of uneducated god-fearing
bible-thumping
idiots duncan who has a heart of gold
and actually tries to win over aaron by
making an effort to read
is put down when she finds out he's been
reading conspiracy
websites i think the show missed a great
opportunity to teach aaron that you
can't judge a book by its cover
not all southerners are gun-toting flat
earthers who are anti-vaccination
on this majestic flat
earth of ours they could have done a
whole arc revealing aaron's own bias and
prejudice through the character of
duncan where she realizes there is good
in the side she is ostracized and has
ostracized her all aaron does when she
arrives in wild horse colorado is
complain about the people
they're backward right dirt bikes and
aren't cool and progressive like her
friends in dc
maybe if she put in some effort she may
find things aren't always what they seem
and she'd learn
and grow as a character aaron is taken
to the middle of nowhere to find the
party she was invited to is a crack
party
cocaine is a hell of a drug in the
command center mark tells captain ellie
to disarm the weapons rendering them
useless
he makes an impassioned speech about how
easily people forget about the mistakes
of the past leaving them susceptible to
repeat the same mistakes over and over
forget how bad polio was people stop
taking vaccines
forget how bad world wars are people
start puffing out their chest
at the same time kick grabaston who is
the head of the air force has descended
upon space force to take control he
stopped by duncan who asked to see his
id card a call back to episode one where
he wouldn't let dr mallory in because he
didn't have his
pushing duncan aside graviston orders
mark to go through with the attack but
it's too late
all the weapons have been disarmed so
grabaston has mark arrested for treason
and
orders the spacemen to attack the
chinese with wrenches
aaron calls her dad who surprisingly
still is able to have a phone
conversation when he's tied up he can't
be there for her but this time it's
because he actually can't
now aaron will have to deal with having
two parents in jail
she even calls duncan and her mom
duncan's tied up and her mom is in jail
erin was right she's totally alone when
she needs people now more than ever
erin will need to learn to do things on
her own she won't always have her
parents
so she grabs a bike and takes off dr
mallory is arrested too and mark uses
his lighter to escape good thing because
as erin escapes she's chased down by the
crackheads on dirt bikes but mark
is there to save her he's commandeered a
chopper which scares them off
and if things couldn't get any more
unbelievable mark finds his wife in the
desert having escaped from prison
she was able to escape with the help
from a prison guard louise who she has a
romantic relationship with
things on the moon have also taken a
turn the spacemen have disabled the
oxygen of the chinese base and rendered
it uninhabitable but upon returning to
their own base they've found it's been
trashed this gives
off the impression that they're stranded
but it seems as though their rocket is
still intact my guess for season 2 is
that they have to come back to earth and
much of that plot will deal with
starting a new base before the chinese
one of the plot points that's not
entirely explored but could drastically
shape next season is the drilling on the
moon
in episode 9 we learned that the chinese
are mining a substance known as helium-3
or h3 for short scientists have
speculated that this material could be a
source for future energy
but that still leaves us with mark if he
goes back to space force he'll be
court-martialed he's aiding his wife a
convicted felon in her escape
it seems the only way out for mark is if
he gets some sort of presidential pardon
but knowing how wacky this show can
sometimes get who knows what surprises
await us next season thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like this video
and subscribe i'm always coming out with
new content you can also follow me on
twitter at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much